ايضا الينا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميد الياس حنا اهلا بك
العميد الياس دعنا نقرا معك جمله هذه
التطورات ما تعلق منها بما وصفه مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني بانه يدخل ضمن الهجوم
المضاد من خلال العمليات النوعيه التي تمت
في الايام الماضيه سواء في البحر الاسود
او حتى في داخل العمق الروسي او ما تعلق
بالتسريع فيما يتعلق بطائره اف 16 واخيرا
هذا الانتشار للاسلحه النوويه الغير
استراتيجيه في بيلاروسيا لو جمعنا كل هذه
المؤشرات تصب في اي اتجاه العميد الياس
هناك عده مؤشرات في عده اتجاهات هناك ما
يسمى بعمليات الالهاء او عمليات الخداع
لصرف الانظار عن اين سيكون هذا الهجوم وهو
الذي قد يكون في عده اتجاهات ولكن الاتجاه
العام والذي قد يعطي نتيجه على المدى
البعيد هو في جنوب اوكرانيا وليس في الشرق
كما يقال هذه عمليات تحضير يعني حتى
العمليات داخل الاراضي الروسيه لن تؤدي
الى تحضير الهجوم هي عمليات تهدف الى
اظهار روسيه على انها غير قادره على حمايه
حدودها وواحده منها ما جرى في الكرملين
اثنين هي اجبار القوات الروسيه على
الانتشار والتثبيت في مكان ما لعدم الذهاب
الى مكان اخر للقتال في حال الحصول على او
التحضير لهجوم معين اثنين او ثلاثه عبد
القادر دائما الهدف هو منع القوات الروسيه
من اللوجستيه من القياده والسيطره
وبالتالي ضرب العمق من هنا على سبيل
المثال الصاروخ الانجليزي الفرنسي ستورم
شادو
الكروز والذي يصل مداه الى 250 كم وهو
قادر على ضرب العمق الروسي خاصه داخل شبه
جزيره القرب اما النووي فقد نتحدث عنه
قريبا
يعني حتى وقت قريب كانت الولايات المتحده
تحاول ان تنقى بنفسها عن اي تورط لاي
اجهزه او اي اسلحه تزود بها اوكرانيا في
ضرب العمق الروسي او اي مصالح روسيه الان
هل يختلف الوضع هل تغيرت استراتيجيه
الولايات المتحده بهذا الخصوص
لا اعتقد ليلى لانه هناك ما يسمى بالوضوح
الاستراتيجي للرئيس بايدن منذ بدء الحرب
هو اليوم قادر على الانكار حتى القياده
الاوكرانيه هي قادره على الانكار وبالرغم
مما ورد في جزيره في جريده نيويورك تايمز
هي قادره على الانكار وكانه
مقاومه روسيه ضمن الاراضي الروسيه وحتى
عمليه الكرملين والتنصت عليها تبين انها
من صنع او من تحضير شيء معين داخل الحكومه
الاوكرانيه مع قدره رئيس الينسكي على
الانكار ولكن هذا الامر لن يفيد العمليات
العسكريه في العمق انها مرحله او صوره
لضرب صوره الرئيس بوتين في الكلام اظهار
الموضوع على ان روسيا ليست قادره على
الانتصار من هنا قد ياتي الاستعداد الروسي
وموضوع نشر هو ليس نشر ليلى هو عمليه هو
عمليه خزن هذه الاسلحه التكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا
بالعوده ايضا الى موضوع طائرات سته عشر
وبالتركيز على مسرح به وتابعناك قبل قليل
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه بالاشاره الى
ان انشاء قوه يمكن ان تكافئ روسيا في هذه
الحرب يحتاج الى وقت طويل وقال ما نقوم به
حتى الان يؤتي اكوله
وكانه هناك حرج امريكي فيما يتعلق بطائره
اللبسه عشر هل من تفسير لذلك
عبد القادر
المعادله التي التي اعتمدتها امريكا في
تزويد اوكرانيا تقوم على اربعه اسس مهمه
واحد الحاجه الميدانيه لهذه الاسلحه اثنين
القدره على التشغيل ثلاثه القدره على
التعهد وبالتالي عدم اثاره حفيظه روسيه من
عدم الذهاب الى السلاح غير التقليدي ومنها
النووي اليوم بدل الاسلحه اسلحه الطيران
هناك الصواريخ البعيده المدى تؤدي دور
الطيران وبالتالي هناك منظومه دفاع جويه
اصبحت مكتمله حتى موضوع الاف 16 عبد
القادر ليس بالعدد المطلوب هي تطلب 200 قد
تحصل على 60 ولكن يبقى متى العدد التدريب
وادخالها في المنظومه العسكريه وهل ستكون
هي اساسيه في الهجوم لا اعتقد الوقت لا
يسمح بذلك
الخبير العسكري الاستراتيجي من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا